hey yes what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about the global market i
would like to show you what kind of
indicators you can use to build a view
on the global market about the sentiment
which is very important to take some
trades once again this is gonna be more
a global approach of how to assess the
health of the global economy so let's
get into it
[Music]
so i selected here a few indicators that
i'm gonna show you quickly and talk
about and explain to you why we look at
this i remind you guys that i used to
work for uh six years as a professional
trader uh in banking and that this is
where i learned
to use this i also work with gabrielle
on discord who was a trader for 10 years
as well in the commodity market so we
are communicating a lot because we work
together right now and he's uh teaching
me a lot of things about commodities
that can be used to assess the health of
the global economy so i'm going to show
you that because i think it's very cool
so first thing
let's have a look at the global market
so i'm going to use spy but nasdaq is
working too so i'm not gonna spend too
much time on the tier here i just wanted
to show you on the daily time frame okay
i'm just gonna analyze the move since
the end of the covet so we have one two
three uh i didn't know if the third was
finished and we're doing a force or not
but now it seems to me that
the third is not complete because this
correction is too shallow once again to
be the correction of the whole move here
you can just measure to know if the
correction is
deep enough to be considered as a
correction you just measure the move it
was supposed to correct so here the
fourth wave is supposed to correct the
third wave uh we checked that and we see
that we didn't go to the 23.6 percent so
even 23.6 retracement of fibonacci is
not enough for correction to be i mean
good enough deep enough so we i we would
need to go to the 405 level for that
move to have corrected so it didn't
correct so it's still the same move all
right so we're still in the third wave
so right now uh just looking at this
chart
uh here
i was bearish here i took a bearish
position and most of it
took profits around here on blackrock
but whatever and
here uh because we had a bearish
position as well on this one but it's
not the question here what is
interesting to see guys is that we now
have the breakout on the spi so first
indicator the global market so spy which
is the tracker of the s p 500
so we can see that if we take this
trendline so the blue one we have the
breakout we had the breakout the day
before so it was already bullish and we
have the confirmation with the weekly
close above this level above the moving
averages above everything so this is
very bullish now
we're gonna try to check the other
indicators that we know we can use to
see if this all goes together so the
first one that to me is the most obvious
is to check the vix i was a volatility
trader so i know the vix so basically
very easy way to assess if there is fear
in the market or not if the vix is
trading above 20 then it means that
everything can happen and if the vix is
below 20 it means things are doing
better here during the move down we had
a vix that went to 28. so there was a
lot of uncertainty at this levels all
right
the s p 500 was at this time going lower
with quite sharp moves
and then we
basically started to go lower and we
break out below the strand liner so can
we use trend lines on the vix i would be
careful but it's still interesting to
have i would maybe more use horizontal
levels you know like for example like
this so we can expect maybe the vix to
come back to 12 if the market really
gets quiet we have us here a sloping
trend line that is broken and it's still
signal but i mean i would not take
trades based on this but it's still
interesting to look at so the vix is at
16.3 breaking out below trend line and
uh probably heading lower so this goes
together of course with the spy breakout
so the first indicator that we look at
is the vix and is giving us positive
signals for the global market as well
now more interestingly guys i want to
talk uh here about the copper so gabriel
explained to me this technique that is
basically so you check the copper and
the copper is called dr copper
because it's very good indicator of the
health of the global market because
basically china is using a lot of copper
and whenever the economy is working well
they consume a lot the demand is high
and so the price of the copper goes
higher so whenever the copper is
suddenly moving much higher it means
that there is a lot of growth expected
from china which means a lot of uh
growth in the whole world because i
remind you that china is still the
economy that contributes the most to the
global growth so uh we have a breakout
on the copper and we had it actually
before we have this breakout for one two
it's the third day when the spy
three days ago was at the bottom guys
all right so this is one of the reasons
we were starting to be bullish here but
we wait we were waiting for all the
signals to come so right now we have it
so once again we're gonna increase the
sizes we use in our live training
portfolios on discord followers guys if
you want to see what we do there so a
link in the description so yeah the
copper is making a nice breakout as you
guys can see it had support on the 200
day moving average not very clean but
still so what can we expect from this we
have a resistance at this level all
right so let's see what's happening
around this level probably a small
rejection and then if we move higher
this breakout would be again the
something we're gonna look at to know uh
if the global market is gonna push
higher and if we have this signal
probably before the move up on the spy
we're gonna just try to anticipate by
buying the dip on some stocks maybe
another indicator that is interesting to
look at guys uh and you know about that
it's the dxy so what is the dxy is just
the price of the us dollar i guess
against a basket of major
currencies like euro yen i think there
is some u1 now as well
so it's basically the price of the
dollar against the all the other world's
currencies so whenever there is fear in
the market people rush for the dollar
the reason behind is that most of the
debt emitted in the world is emitted in
dollars so if the dollar if i mean
things go bad you want to have dollars
to pay back the debt so people just rush
for dollars they're gonna dump their for
their domestic currency and buy dollar
because i mean i'm talking about foreign
countries because they need dollar to
pay the debt and they're scared the
dollar will be higher and with their uh
currency being devaluated maybe it's
going to be more expensive for them to
pay back the interest of the debt so
this is the reason why the dollar is
always going higher uh usually quite
sharply whenever there is fear in the
market and we can see that here the
dollar went higher so we had here a nice
support
so at this level we could have for
example assume that you know would have
a rebound this was on the 8th of
september you see it was here so at the
very beginning of the correction we had
the dollar that had a nice support
reaction here
so we didn't see it at that time so i'm
not saying it's easy all right we were
already doing some live trading on this
code uh we got trapped a bit in the
smooth down let's be honest but you know
now we're gonna pay more attention of
course but it's not easy to look at
everything together but just keep in
mind that it's one of the indicators
that can be used and that is here would
have been helpful right now we went to
the recent uh high that was around
94.5 so as long as we are contained here
so we're probably going to find support
here let's see if here we go higher or
not you see if we break that it's going
to be very good for the global market
and the other on the other hand if we
come back here and break this guys this
would be the signal things
are bad
but i'm very convinced we won't have it
because we have positive signal on the
dxy positive signal on the copper
positive signals on the vix
positive signal on the spy uh i mean
technically and about the news as well
everground default seems to be under
control and biden financing plan has
passed through at the senate so
everything looks very good for a end of
your rally i'm going to give you my
targets for the spy but first let's
check the last indicator that can be
very good to use as well for the same
reason it's a bit more tricky because
there is a storage factor that is quite
important about the price of the oil
because it's very expensive to store but
it's still a very good indicator of the
global demand about the global growth
and we can see that we have so we had
already this sloping breakout okay here
so this was the first indicator so let's
see when this happened
this happened on the 27th of sept where
was the spy it was at the lows okay so
here it was already in good indicator
that the oil was breaking out which is
good and then we had the confirmation
with by making a new high above october
18th level october 2018 level so which
is a 77 so right now we are in uh no
man's land guys next resistance where is
it okay let's try to find the next
resistance all right we have one here so
we have actually some room
let's see what's happening here but
probably we're gonna get rejected so
this whenever the oil is here we can
expect a correction on the global market
so once again guys i've been working in
this environment for many years and i
can tell you it's not easy to you know
spot the right one you're gonna often
see oh i have a signal here and the
opposite signal over there and you don't
know which one to use but sometimes they
all go in the same same direction okay
here for example crude is positive dx y
is positive copper is positive vix is
positive and breakout on the spy so i
might be wrong once again it's always
possible but it looks very very good
here so what can we expect on this spy
as usual guys breakout it's a sloping
breakout so it's usually retested so we
can expect a move higher than a re-test
and then again a move higher and thus
developing in five waves in terms of
levels what can we expect
so basically i think we can go close to
this trend line all right by the end of
the year so it's uh s p around 408
i mean 4800 so this would be a very nice
move up and i can tell you that we will
try our best to jump in the stocks that
look the best and to try to make some
nice p l in our live training so in
terms of percentage move in in a matter
of maybe two months we can expect six
seven eight percent guys so i think
there is a very nice opportunity coming
now once again let's be careful so let's
check everything else on the market but
for now we don't have any bad signals
coming so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys